and I want to go even further and talk a
little bit about the 2017 calendar which
is now available I mentioned to you
earlier this week that the 2017 david
pakman show calendar is now available
and the cover is absolutely
extraordinary it's a caricature of me as
a referee basically a refereeing a match
a boxing match between Donald Trump and
Hillary Clinton you see Jeb Bush in the
background you see President Obama in
the background and so many other people
and every single page is just great
original artwork from artist Dan Burke
and uh you see that Louis shows up you
see that Pat Robertson shows up Trump
Clinton Jeb all sorts of political
characters show up there and you can get
your calendar and if you want to think
about this as a coloring book by all
means if you want to think about this as
a comic book by all means you just want
to think about it as a calendar to put
on the wall with something funny to look
at each month absolutely david
pakman.com slash calendar 17 is the
website where you can get if you want
just the calendar you can get it at
david pakman.com slash calendar 17 if
you want to get the calendar for free
you can do that at david pakman.com
slash calendar 17 with a yearly David
Pakman show membership the goal for this
year is 350 calendars last year we sold
201 and I would love to do 350 this year
and you know what if you've been
thinking about getting a membership
which includes the daily bonus show for
members only and includes members only
audio and video commercial free streams
of the show all of those great benefits
if you've been interested in those now
you can get those and you can get the
calendar for free but you must go to
david pakman.com slash calendar 17